[Musik]
schwarze gebäude schwarze wohnungen
Schwarzerde
Jetzt machen wir Orthophotos, die Bilder von sind
Höhen von verschiedenen Seiten des zerstörten
Gebäude mit beschädigten Leitungen
Kraftübertragung durch Brücken
Wir fixieren die Dimensionen auf die gleiche Weise mit den Feldern
der Trichter
Wir erfassen die Art der Zerstörung des Fahrers
dass es eine Projektilflugbahn gibt und das
Alles wird sich auf internationaler Ebene beweisen
gleiche Verbrechen der Russischen Föderation gegen
Zivilbevölkerung
[Musik]
Ende des 14. Jahres habe ich studiert
im 15. Jahr Wing Copter zu steuern
ging in das Kriegsgebiet im Osten
der Ukraine am Abend auftreten
Die Ukraine braucht Drohnen verschiedener Typen
Kopter und Art der durchzuführenden Flügel
verschiedene Aufgaben an der Front und an der Front
Evakuierung von Zivilisten, wenn eine Person geht
am Boden und sieht es nicht von oben
viel mehr Chance zu bekommen
die Unannehmlichkeit der Situation im Kampf oder darunter
Beschuss Wenn eine Person mindestens hat
Die obigen Informationen können minimiert werden
Verlust von Arbeitskräften
da dieser Abgang der zweite war, habe ich ihn wieder übertönt
Es gab Satelliten, aber die Probe ging verloren
Sie sind gerade gestürmt, nun, es ist das Phantom
Jetzt kommt ein neuer Chip zu uns nach Hause
Kreis gab diesem Prozess einen neuen Begriff John
geht zum Haus
nicht wirklich
Wir haben eine Community von Betreibern
UAVs verschiedener Typen Wir teilen Fähigkeiten
Wir teilen unsere Erfahrung, denn jetzt in
Neue Yaki-Maschinen kommen in die Ukraine
die ihre eigenen Arbeitsspezifika haben und welche nicht
Sie können keine Bewertung finden, außer dass
im Englischen ist es sehr selten
maximal
außerdem arbeite ich
Nun, jetzt gibt es eine Trainingseinheit
Flüge von Soldaten der Streitkräfte der Ukraine in der Nähe von
Feldbedingungen und um
die Taktik der Geheimdienstleitung auszuarbeiten und
den Schützen decken, um
Unter den Bedingungen der Schlacht war alles so sicher wie möglich
und so schnell wie möglich
Erfahrung muss geteilt, gemeistert werden
verschiedene Arten von UAVs sind ein Muss
lehre diejenigen, die gerade erst anfangen und tun
ein solches Netzwerk in der Armee, damit mehr Menschen
konnte Drohnen sicher einsetzen
es 20 sind unterschiedlich Zum Beispiel wenn
es gibt eine Pause, es gibt eine Änderung der Pflicht und was
mehr Leute wissen, wie es geht, als
mehr es rettet Leben
Jede Drohne hat ihre eigene Flugzeitreserve
und dann müssen Sie aufladen Und wo
Gebühr, wenn zum Beispiel Strom
es gibt kein
Je mehr Vögel, desto länger die Zeit
Wir brauchen solche Copter für den Flug
Es war schwer zu zerstören
Der Feind ist eine Funk-Elektro-Kampfstation
die den Betrieb von Drohnen stören. Eine Drohne kann
Fall Drone kann verloren gehen Drone Can
wahrscheinlich der Route folgen
Wir brauchen Waffen.“ Sie kamen zu uns
Eindringlinge mit Waffen, sie sind bewaffnet
herausgebracht und in Konflikten mit Waffen getötet
unsere lokale Bevölkerung besuchte unsere
Soldaten haben unsere Entbindungsheime erschossen
Krankenhäuser Schulen machten sie Waffen wir
Wir müssen uns hier mit Waffen wehren, weil in
Wir befinden uns im Krieg, wir brauchen Waffen jeglicher Art
Der Himmel könnte von einer Waffe bedeckt sein, die es könnte
würde feindliche Ausrüstung aus der Ferne zerstören
gefährlich, diese feindliche Technik zu entdecken
Blockiere ihre Arbeit und neutralisiere sie
Nur so können wir gewinnen
[Musik]
Die Ukraine verteidigt jetzt nicht nur ihre eigene
Territorium Und auch die gesamte zivilisierte Welt a
wenn Sie Ukrainisch unterstützen möchten
die Armee
wirksam beim Feind
Kaufe und sende uns Drohnen bzw
Sie unterstützen mit Geld die beteiligten Fonds
Durch den Kauf von Drohnen kehren diese Gelder zurück
Es lebe der Fan Serhiy Prytula und die Stiftung zusammen
Foi Ukraine
es ist gut
Nein, ich bin auf meinen Händen
ok du willst
Warum nehmen wir ihn mit und was tun?
[Lachen]